who could have imagined that a man who
spent his days feeding pigeons in a park
near the New York Public Library was one
of the most Brilliant Minds in the world
Nikola Tesla was so smart that he could
picture all his ideas and the designs
for them in his head he didn't need
models or drawings although the Serbian
American was a famous inventor he died
penniless after his most ambitious
project Came Crashing Down
how dramatic a turn his life took at one
point he could have easily been the
richest person on the planet royalty
payments on his alternating current
power system were worth an absolute
Fortune hundreds of millions of dollars
adjusted for inflation today our world
is still predominantly powered by AC in
which the flow of electricity changes
Direction periodically as a result It
suffers less energy loss when
transmitted over long distances on the
other hand Thomas Edison's direct
current DC travels in only one direction
and is tough to transmit over long
distances
AC is the type of electric current
generated by most power plants including
Tesla's plant at Niagara Falls
Niagara Falls started the
electrification of the world Tesla and
American industrialist George
Westinghouse built the world's first
hydroelectric power plant here in 1895
using AC to harness the power of the
falls after such a great success Tesla
could have retired very comfortably but
instead he was determined to outdo
himself by achieving a new form of
global communication trouble is he had
no money to turn his latest dream into
reality how can that be considering his
AC system should have made him very
wealthy Westinghouse purchased Tesla's
AC patents for sixty thousand dollars in
the form of five thousand dollars cash
and 150 shares in Westinghouse electric
and Manufacturing Company
Westinghouse also agreed to pay Tesla
royalties based on how much electricity
he could sell amounting to two dollars
fifty cents per horsepower of electrical
capacity Soul Tesla should have been
rich but he wasn't because of his kind
heart
westinghouse's company suffered greatly
as it battled Edison's company in which
Edison tried to show how dangerous
Tesla's AC was Westinghouse was nearly
bankrupt an industrialist JP Morgan
intended to starve at westinghouse's
company and buy up Tesla's patents in an
effort to dominate the energy Market
Westinghouse begged Tesla for relief
from having to pay the promised
royalties to try to save his company
in response in what can only be
described as a gesture of pure
selflessness Tesla tore up his contract
he was so moved by his friends please
Nikola Tesla single-handedly saved the
Westinghouse company he was grateful to
George Westinghouse his friend who
believed in him who never swindled him
and besides Tesla had even bigger ideas
to pursue
yet walking away from the royalties
would come back to haunt him because it
left him struggling financially to the
point where it dashed his Ultimate Dream
after the success of Niagara Falls Tesla
returned to his lab there was nothing he
loved more than experimenting even the
fire that gutted his New York laboratory
couldn't stop it we don't know what
caused the fire
in 1891 he had invented the remarkable
Tesla coil which produced high voltage
high frequency alternating current
electricity with high frequencies he
pioneered the use of x-rays for medical
purposes this is an x-ray Tesla took of
his own hand but that paled in
comparison to the time he waved vacuum
tubes around like a Jedi Illuminating
them wirelessly after having transmitted
energy through the air the wireless
transmission of energy became his
lifelong obsession
he imagined a wireless Globe
transmitting free electricity across the
Atlantic with no wires and took his idea
to the wealthy American Banker JP Morgan
Morgan put up a hundred fifty thousand
dollars to build a giant transmission
tower at Warden cliff on Long Island New
York Tesla imagined that it would be the
first of a network of towers worldwide
he believed these towers would allow him
to send electricity through the
atmosphere which anyone with a correct
equipment could then tap into
this image is an artistic impression
kindly supplied to me by Alan Bellows
with damn interesting the real Tower
never crackled with electricity
Tesla explained at the time it will be
possible for a businessman in New York
to dictate instructions and have them
instantly appear in type at his office
in London or elsewhere
he was well ahead of his time it was
incredibly prescient of him to imagine a
Global Wireless communication system
similar to what the internet offers us
today
but not long after construction began in
1901 Tesla started to run out of money
he appealed to JP Morgan for more
financing without any luck investors
were instead throwing their support
behind a young Italian inventor
in 1901 gulielmo Marconi successfully
sent a radio signal from England to
Newfoundland Canada he used Tesla's
radio patents to do it Tesla realized
his coils could transmit and receive
powerful radio signals and he applied
for radio patents which the U.S patent
office granted in 1900 so Marconi's feet
didn't bother Tesla who remarked to one
of his Engineers Marconi is a good
fellow let him continue he is using 17
of my patents Marconi tried to file
radio patents himself in the U.S but the
patent office turned down repeated
applications as it argued they were too
similar to Tesla's however as Tesla
found out things can change in 1904 the
patent office reversed its earlier
decisions and awarded Marconi a patent
for the invention of the radio
the reason behind the reversal has never
been explained
some suspect the powerful backing
Marconi received in the United States
including that by Edison played a role
Marconi was credited as the inventor of
the radio and became Rich he even won
the Nobel Prize in physics as a result
Tesla was Furious and sued the Marconi
company for patent infringement yet he
couldn't afford to litigate a case
against a big Corporation he also
couldn't find anyone interested in
investing more money in his Tower of
Dreams
in 1917 Tesla's Tower was dismantled to
pay off his creditors
Tesla was in debt to The Heirs of the
Waldorf Astoria Hotel where he had been
staying when his friend and Wealthy
investor John Jacob Aster died on the
Titanic Asters airs demanded that Tesla
pay his debt he did so by demolishing
his Tower and selling the scrap metal
when his greatest dream was Out Of Reach
Tesla lamented it is not a dream it is a
simple feat of scientific electrical
engineering only expensive blind
faint-hearted doubting world
Tesla began to withdraw from that world
he showed signs of obsessive compulsive
disorder he was obsessed with the number
three and would walk around a block
three times before entering a building
he'd count his steps wherever he walked
he compulsively counted the cubic
content of bowls of soup or cups of
coffee otherwise his meals were not
enjoyable
near the end of his life he became
obsessed with pigeons especially a white
female pigeon he is believed to have
said I love that pigeon I loved her as a
Man Loves a Woman and she loved me as
long as I had her there was a purpose in
my life
Tesla never married
the pigeon apparently died in his arms
and at that point he knew his life's
work was finished
Nikola Tesla would live out the last 10
years of his life at the New Yorker
Hotel paid for by the Westinghouse
corporation which also gave him a
consulting fee of 125 dollars a month
this is the company that was in debt to
him for having given up royalties worth
millions of dollars for the sake of his
friend George Westinghouse
he began to fade away into history one
of the few exceptions being the time he
turned 75 and made the cover of Time
Magazine
Tesla died in his hotel room alone on
January 7 1943 without of Henny to his
name he was 86 years old
a few months after his death the U.S
Supreme Court overturned Marconi's radio
patent in favor of Tesla's but the court
had a selfish reason for doing so the
Marconi company was suing the U.S
government for use of its patents in
World War one so the court avoided the
lawsuit by simply restoring Tesla's
patents
when I worked on an earlier story about
Nikola Tesla some pointed out that the
Forgotten genius was not an apt title
personally I grew up in Canada learning
much more about Thomas Edison an
American than Nikola Tesla an immigrant
who was born in present-day Croatia
but perhaps viewers have a point and he
really isn't forgotten today Tesla is
once again capturing the Public's
imagination because an electric car
company Bears his name
Elon musk's company paid homage to
Nikola Tesla in 2022 with a dazzling
display of drones that formed a Visage
of the brilliant engineer
Tesla was undoubtedly one of the most
famous figures in stem and if you've
been inspired by his Brilliance and wish
to brush up on your math science and
computer science skills brilliant is a
great way to learn interactively and
it's free for you to try out with my
custom link I personally use brilliant
to go through their logic puzzles which
I find have strengthened my reasoning
skills I know my viewers especially love
their computer science fundamentals
course where you can program drones in
an Amazon warehouse their scientific
thinking course is full of interactive
exercises that will give you a solid
handle on the principles of engineering
and the laws of physics in this exercise
you have to make the bridge as rigid as
possible with as few beams as possible
and if you'd like to improve your math
skills I'd highly recommend the Everyday
Math course where you can see numbers in
a new light in everyday contacts there's
something for everyone whether you're a
student or already working brilliant is
free for you to try out if you head to
the custom link in my description
brilliant.org newsthink in the first 200
people who signed up with my custom link
will get 20 off Brilliance annual
premium membership which gives you
unlimited access to all the course
offerings including the most advanced
courses thanks for watching for news
think I'm Cindy Palm
[Music]